sometimes you see something and then you
have to talk about it I have no reason
to suspect that my subscriber base would
particularly care about this film or
that it will be on their radar that
would be the kind of thing they would
normally enjoy maybe for some of you
would great maybe for some of you
absolutely not
I don't care everybody should watch
Hannah Gatsby Nannette I am NOT going to
go into a great amount of detail as to
why because honestly seeing that it's a
comedy special it's a little over an
hour seeing it is an experience and it
is an experience that should be taken
with as little foreknowledge as possible
so honestly my wreck my honest
recommendation for you even though I
plan to not go into a lot of specifics
about what what goes on it is to stop
this video right now go watch it it's on
Netflix if you have a subscription it's
free then after you've seen it come back
and you'll understand why I need to talk
about this at least a little at least to
bring it to people's attention I was
gonna say bring people's attention to it
it's it's bigger than I am it's it's
trending you know it's doing all that
stuff and rightfully so
Hannah Gatsby is a stand-up comic who I
was not familiar with she is Australia
well Tasmanian to be more specific and
this was her final comedy tour and she
is I mean as one might guess from how
she chooses to dress and present she is
a lesbian and that is a pretty
significant part of her show you know
much the same degree that being
transvestite is a significant part of
Eddie is our show it
kind of it's not not necessarily
everything that has talked about is
about that
but it is foundational to what goes on
and she is funny she's very funny she's
very clever and she's she's very good at
cycling back on points already made
she's she's very good at the callback
joke and when this as this thing goes
along and it shifts and its overall
purpose becomes clearer it goes from
being a very good comedy special to I I
was gonna say I don't want to be
hyperbolic but screw it I mean this
honestly into a work of genius this is a
brilliant piece of work
and I've now watched it twice and I
loved it the first time and I appreciate
it all the more have you seen it twice
because having seen it twice I see how I
was able to see how the jokes that were
told earlier in the special lay the
foundation of what is to come and how
where things ultimately end up should
have lost me there have been stand-up
specials of similar structure and intent
to this that I've seen not of the same
caliber but of similar construction and
intent and by and large they've lost me
and I think now having seen this I
realized the reason that they lost me is
because before the shift happens what
came before didn't feel didn't build as
firm a foundation for what happens later
to stand on here it absolutely does
astoundingly so and if you're still
watching at this point you had you
didn't take my advice and go watch the
thing
here's what I'm going to say as to why
everyone should watch this when I say
everyone I mean everyone anyone over the
age of 13 should watch this men-women
non-binary straight gay everyone
everyone should watch this because what
what she talks about and the way she
frames it and the context she gives it
and not only the story that she tells
but the way she lays out how telling
this story matters and why it matters
and has shaped her life in the telling
of this story to be blunt about it it is
going to make people a significant
number of people very uncomfortable it
made me uncomfortable and it should the
things that it made me uncomfortable
about are things that I should be
uncomfortable with the kind of things
that I do believe the vast majority of
us are uncomfortable with but we don't
we we don't look from the perspective
that forces us to deal with them and
again I I don't I don't want to go into
detail but even you know taking into
account my gender fluctuating stance
stance is the wrong word existence there
we go
at the end of the day the majority of my
life has been presented as if not lived
as man and I said everyone should watch
this and I stand by that but absolutely
any and every straight heterosexual man
[Music]
should watch this
because I've never I've seen attempts at
bringing a female's perspective truly to
the forefront in a way that is
accessible to people other than you know
more than just other women and I have
seen that fail and I've seen people with
the kind of intent that the SPECIAL has
give a appear to give up and just optic
reach and preach to the choir this is
not for the choir this is for everybody
but it's for men especially and even as
I took the hat off and I let my hair
down and normally that's to establish my
gender fluidity I did it because I need
to just talk plainly about the fact that
as someone born male raised in the
mentality of a society that exalts
masculinity and who has enjoyed the
privileges that come with being born and
presenting male in this society
I needed to see this
no matter how open-minded you think you
are guys and I'm talking to the guys now
the perspective that is presented here
is one you cannot reach on your own and
that's not me saying you're incapable of
understanding a woman lesbian or
anything like that i'm saying that your
experiences your experience and your
experience is not the experience that
she talks about but she relays that
experience in a way that will make you
stop and think about things that you I
all of us need to stop and think about
and I'm not gonna go into any more
detail than that but this know it's
funny for a very long time even after
everything that came out I did honestly
believe I would never see a comedy
special better than Bill Cosby himself
and after everything that we now know
about Bill Cosby came out that sucked
but it was something I had kind of
accepted because that was a brilliantly
constructed stand-up comedy film and I
did not think I would ever see better
Bill Cosby's not even my favorite
comedian
you know we again setting aside
everything about him before all that was
known he still wasn't even my favorite
he probably wasn't even my top five but
that's special I did think was as good
as anyone could do this blew that away
what Hannah Gatsby has achieved with
this piece of work as far as I'm
concerned his seminal and I think it
should be taught in schools and I think
it should be examined by academics not
just because of the points that she's
making but the way in which she makes
them this is a work of brilliance and
it's a work of brilliance on a topic and
coming from a source that needs to be
seen and to be heard and if you have not
seen it and I do see it I have no idea
if this is available in audio form I
don't know if you can buy it as a as
like a you know I as a released comedy
album audio version don't watch it see
it see her laugh cuz York's you're
supposed to laugh but listen listen very
very closely and I hope that maybe just
one person who sees this video goes and
sees that who might not have otherwise
and can have an experience like I had
watching that
I love stand-up comedy I've always loved
stand-up comedy if I was in my ascent
upcoming I tried to do stand-up comedy
didn't work but the power that this
special has I don't know I mean I've
never really talked about Stanhope
County before it's not something imagine
I'll talk about much if at all ever
again I don't know if it's something
that anybody watching cares about I
don't care you need to watch this thank
you for listening if you took my advice
and you did watch it and then came back
and saw the rest of this you know why I
talk about it
if you didn't go off and watch it before
watch it now and then come back drop
something out in the comments let's talk
about it
like subscribe support me on patreon
follow me on Twitter all that stuff
there's links for all those things down
in the description but until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]